[Music]
foreign
of the after show today
for the very first time we are going to
be breaking down a series not just an
episode but an entire season and what
better series to start with than House
of the Dragon the prequel to The
immensely famous Game of Thrones and now
house and the dragon is famous in its
own right hugely successful people have
absolutely loved it and before we go any
further I should warn you that this is
going to be a full spoiler conversation
so if you haven't watched all of House
of the Dragon go do that and then come
back or stay with us whatever you choose
but just know this is your spoiler
warning I do not wish to get married
Steven I do not exist about tradition
and Duty Runner none of it needs be this
way in truth no one's here for me
so if I'm going to be talking about
House of the dragon and a little Game of
Thrones we need an expert we need a
die-hard passionate person and so who
better than Andreas Cabrera hello how
are you hello I'm so excited and yes
House of the Dragon Game of Thrones give
me all that good stuff I love it well
before we get into your overall reaction
to the series and my overall reaction to
the series I want to give the Tomato
Meter score and the audience score on
this series that you made a meter score
it's certified fresh at 86 and the
audience score almost exactly the same
tiny bit lower 84 the critics consensus
is covering an era of tenuous peace with
ferocious albeit abbreviated Focus House
of the Dragon is an impressive prequel
that exemplifies the court Intrigue that
distinguished its predecessor overall do
you agree with the score or what do you
think
I think it's pretty spot on I actually
do I feel like it's always tough to go a
little too high because you don't want
to over exaggerate and you can always
have room for improvement so I feel like
86 is kind of spot on it's solid for a
series but I would disagree I think it
should have been in the 90s I think this
is an absolutely brilliant first season
of a show
um overall the reason I loved it so much
in in what I didn't expect from it is
that it took its time building suspense
and that is a word that sometimes often
doesn't happen so much in Hollywood
anymore we want you know with superhero
movies and series we want a lot of
action right people are addicted to
action CG that kind of thing fight
scenes Game of Thrones was known for its
Gore and this one really built the
suspense
to the to the argument some people said
it was a little too slow moving but what
did you think about sort of the way that
the season built oh I'm I'm on way
opposite terms I I thought this was
maybe because I'm used to Game of
Thrones I thought this one was so fast I
I felt like it just flew by I felt like
maybe every other episode was like a
very suspenseful crazy episode versus
other shows I've seen that takes a good
Eight Episodes to build the suspense so
I I thought this was one of the most
action-packed fast-moving quick Pace
kind of shows considering it is in this
westerosa universe
I thought there was a lot of talking
there was a lot of when are they going
to get to the Civil War maybe and maybe
you knew that they weren't necessarily
going to get to it in season one I
didn't know that going into it I kept
waiting for this explosion and there
were explosions throughout the season
but I thought for the most part in terms
of an all-out War brawling brutality
grotesqueness I thought it was a little
tame in that sense which was good for me
because that meant I could handle it
because I'm not really good at that with
that kind of thing
oh yeah especially compared to Game of
Thrones considering what they do I mean
obviously there's some horrific scenes
in this show as well but when it comes
to actual military battle and all that
kind of stuff I felt like they probably
had like two or three moments that were
really up there when it comes to those
type of scenes but they're saving all
that crazy dramatic stuff for Seasons
two and three and four I'm assuming when
it comes to the actual dance of dragons
so did you I know you were a Game of
Thrones fan you're a huge Game of
Thrones fan and I'm gonna ask you to
compare the two
I'm going to ask you to compare the two
how did you find this compared to Game
of Thrones do you liked it more you
liked it less you can't compare it's too
soon what are your thoughts yeah I mean
it's too it's two very different shows
considering they're in the same universe
right I mean it's one of those things
where one of them feels like you have
seven or eight different characters
spanning all over the kingdom even over
uh the sea when it comes to essos with
Danny's storyline throughout Five
Seasons so I feel like Game of Thrones
kind of takes their time to build up
each side character and build up each
Side Story versus this show is very much
centered on one Central story and it
just kind of moves down that track and
this it doesn't really necessarily need
to expand anywhere else so I feel like
when it comes to a first season it's
tough to compare but if I am comparing
Seasons as a whole I still feel like
Game of Thrones has the edge when it
comes to the type of Storytelling that
they build where they're able to expand
a little bit more on the political
Intrigue of Westeros of King's Landing
in a much more uh organic kind of way I
want to say than necessarily House of
the Dragon although I loved House of the
dragon and I feel like it does a really
good thing as well when it comes to the
type of story they're building I feel
like Game of Thrones might have might
have done it a little better at least
for the first Seasons if I'm comparing
season one and season season one to
season one
um so the big thing that people had an
issue with I think and I think maybe
when you're talking about the pace or
the where the time jumps
and then there was a few there was a
couple of time jumps
I was okay with it I'll tell you why
what it first would happen because they
would leave you off in an episode and
you'd be like I cannot wait to see what
happens next I want them to pick up
right where they left off because I was
enjoying sort of like reveling in those
juicy moments and then there would be a
time Jump at the beginning of an episode
and I would go oh this is a little
jarring but then I would go they would
cook me so fast as to what was going on
then within minutes I thought oh I
didn't really need to see what happened
in the last few years they caught me up
and I think that was brilliant on the
part of the show Runners because I think
what they did was even if you weren't a
Game of Thrones fan you got you got a
lot in one season you got a lot of
history you got to you got enough of
these characters and you've got a lot of
story in season one because of that what
were your thoughts on the time Jump
so I saw I saw in the rundown they were
like some people complained about the
time jumps and I was like it it's me I'm
the problem you're the one that's that's
me that was probably all me I complained
about the time jumps mainly because if
I'm being completely honest I have read
Fire and Blood which is the book that is
based on this story of House of the
Dragon which is the dance of dragons
that happens during this time period and
there is so much so much that happens
during this time that I was kind of
frustrated that I was like they kind of
yada yada see it passed a lot of story
with Damon with Lena his first wife with
his girls like there was so much that I
was like so excited that they were going
to get to and that we didn't get to see
and I agree with you though I still
agree with you that when it comes to the
time jumps they did a really good job as
far as catching you up with everything
you needed to know yeah but I really did
feel like if we didn't have those time
jumps and if we just took our time just
a little bit maybe even you know give us
two or three more episodes on certain
story lines I felt like that would have
been perfect
well yeah and I still wish that I had it
like if I had my choice I think I would
have and this was my one complaint about
the time jumps as much as I loved both
all four actresses that played Allison
and raniera's characters
I almost the thing that I found jarring
was first of all you had like the
younger renera have her chemistry you
know with Damon and then you have the
older one that has you have to sort of
re-establish that chemistry with the
same actor you have a different actress
with the same actor now if they had
spent the entire first season with you
know Millie and then gone over you know
in season two with the older character
and you switched out the actor as well
not that I want Matt Smith which
switched out ever but I feel like that
would have inter that wouldn't have
Jarred my brain because you're seeing
some of the characters are being aged
and then some of them aren't
and they're matched up against actors
that were there the whole time that
quite frankly I think Matt Smith had it
in his contract he's like I'm just gonna
look young the whole time I'm just
you're not aging me at all because he
did not age a day he's the only one he's
the only one the Christmas Crystal No
Gray in the hair nothing like come on
Krista cole looks like Millie's age the
whole time he never age I mean so does
Matt Smith to be fair but I feel like
Matt Smith I kind of buy it I don't know
why I buy him if someone told me he's 31
I'd be like sure and then if someone
else said actually he's 48 I'd be like
sure I I buy it I buy his huge age Gap
transformation I think that's the only
character I buy Kristen close a little
bit harder for me to take in but I agree
with you with the Millie aspect of it
all even though to be fair I I do prefer
not prefer but I do really enjoy Emma's
version of rhaenyra uh probably a little
bit more mainly because of her story arc
I feel but I feel like if we did have a
season one with Millie it would have
been a different opportunity for the
story to really expand the universe that
they're trying to build when it comes to
this time period inside of Westeros
because I feel like this pitch in the
actual meeting room for Warner Brothers
was I'm giving you Dragon on Dragon
action I'm giving you Dragon Civil War
and they were like okay we got a bill to
it so you better give me one season of
like building to it and that's it by
season two we better have dragons
fighting each other is what like Mr
Warner Brothers said to the Game of
Thrones showrunners In The House of the
dragon show runner so I feel like there
was this need to kind of rush to the
battles which was which is what we're
gonna get in season two but I feel like
if we didn't have that need it almost
could have been even better if we just
could have built it out a little bit
more yeah and I think maybe overall as a
season you people wouldn't have liked it
as much because you wouldn't have had
that final big you know ending Crescendo
ending that they had but
it would have been and maybe also they
didn't they didn't necessarily know how
how popular it was going to be do you
remember how many people were doubting
this we're sorry Game of Thrones and
that seems like so long ago now because
it was so embraced and was trending
number one every single week and
millions and millions 20 million plus
viewers and they just built on that so
they probably maybe had they known in
the beginning how successful it was
going to be they could have said we got
you we're gonna get to that in season
you know two and a half three something
like that
um I want to ask you about it's gonna
put you on the spot your top three
favorite characters in order and then
I'll go oh if you can it's tough right
it's if I was actually thinking about
this last night it's hard not to say
rhaenyra because I feel like gray Nera
especially in that finale it builds up
such an incredible Arc from Millie and
being a little girl to discovering who
she is to struggling with everything
she's struggling with to becoming a
woman becoming a mother and then
becoming a queen and having this giant
responsibility on your shoulders and
trying to overcome this incredible
difficult family Dynamic that happens to
be the entire Kingdom that you're trying
to run it's an incredible story arc an
incredible journey that we have with her
so for me I would probably have to put
her number one considering she is the
main character
number two
I I might put my favorite couple on here
which is corley's and rainey's two and
three uh I love coralies and rainey's I
think they're amazing that's the drift
Mark couple the queen Who Never Was the
princess uh I love Corliss a coreless to
me is like that really old school
ambitious sailor who's lived this
incredible life he's done the nine
voyages all across the world he is
basically a savant with all this world
uh information and knowledge that he has
obtained and power that he's obtained in
just doing it the old-fashioned way so I
really love his character and I love his
journey obviously by the very end of the
episode when he joins renera and then
his wife rainy is being the much more
quiet uh contemplative
she's very offensive she she thinks
before she acts and versus her husband
who just acts I love that character
Dynamic that couple Dynamic I absolutely
love them so I feel like those are my
bottom two and three see
to mean that your favorite moment of the
SE when she wrote in on the Dragon in
episode nine was that your favorite
moment or was that not your favorite
moment it was not no that's actually
something that took me by surprise as
well that was definitely something they
added I was screaming at my TV I wanted
her to torch the crap out of them in
that particular particular moment uh
interesting I have a hard time deciding
my one and two obvi I mean it's gonna be
the two most obvious but
viserys and rhaenyra and yeah we're my
two top but I thought I think a lot of
the reason why I love viscera so much is
I actually chatted with the cast before
I was only shown one episode and then I
did the junket for it
and the thing that has stuck with me is
I asked Patty considine
um
because George RR Martin had said the
biggest conflict in this show is not
between characters but within the
character's own heart so I said what is
your character's biggest conflict and
and Patty said he should never have been
King
and he just wanted peace but I just
thought he was such a brilliant actor I
don't think anybody else has people
calling for an Emmy when you know as
much as he's sort of garnered that
attention for his performance
um I think on paper King viserys could
have easily been a character that
annoyed you because he just sometimes
couldn't take charge he couldn't assert
even though he he tended to side towards
renera a lot of the time he just he
didn't fully put it out there and he
would play both sides and try to keep
everybody happy and that is a character
that I think a lot of actors could have
played him weak or played into the
cliche and he did not you truly felt he
was the heart of the show he truly was
the heart of the show even down to the
Last Supper where he got his final wish
were receivingly everybody maybe could
have possibly gotten along renera like I
said being my second favorite character
um and I and I like both performances
and my third favorite character was
Allison as much as I hated her and I
love to hate her Olivia Cook in my
opinion
besides Patty considine was the standout
actor of season one I thought she had
some absolutely epic moments so um any
supporting characters or or characters
that you didn't love so much in season
one
oh there's plenty okay
let's start with the ones you let's
start with the ones that you the
supporting characters that you liked oh
supported characters that I liked great
um
I feel like I
of you know what I was thinking of these
past couple episodes the the kids are
great I think the kids are great
obviously there's not a lot that they do
in the in the first season but just
Sarah's luceris Bayla Reyna even if uh
Bayla and Reyna have a very small role I
I feel like what they're building
towards is very is very well done they
do a really good job of showing you that
these kids have a good head on their
shoulder and that they're able to
maintain a sense of nobility and a sense
of strength within their own family
um also you know what's a this might be
a hot take this might be my hottest take
to be honest with Saria a lot of people
didn't like messaria but I that's the
White Worm uh played by sonoya Mizuno
who I thought she was great and I
thought her character being the master
of Whispers The Master of information
all around King's Landing and her moment
with Otto is actually one of my favorite
moments in the entire season when she's
telling her about the will of the people
and how she's able to move mountains and
she's able to move so much just based on
her own will and her own information and
that even though he's the most powerful
guy in the world which is Otto because
of him being hand of the king makes him
one of the most powerful if not the most
powerful
even though that's the case she has a
lot of power of her own and I love that
moment of her explaining how she wants
the kids to not fight in uh King's
Landing anymore and she wants a stop to
that and I feel like that was an
incredible moment so I feel like that's
a very underrated side character in my
opinion she's she to me stood out like a
sore thumb like it
It Blend with the rest of the cast and
and that and I think that was
intentional and I I know the actress I
think I've seen her in other things
she doesn't have I mean that was an
accent yes that was an accent okay
that's an accent yes I knew it but I had
to say it but it's an accent also was a
really bold Choice it was it was I know
a lot of people did not like it they
were I liked it uh they were calling her
like
Jamaican Caribbean you know westerosi
like it was definitely a choice but I I
liked it and I I thought it gave her
kind of this this kind of interesting
mix of cultures and and Vibes even
though I know I think she's from lease
in the books but I felt like it worked
and I felt like every scene with her was
interesting and was engaging regardless
of what uh she was saying there was
something interesting and underlying
from every word she was speaking and I
and I absolutely loved her character
especially by the end of these the
season
I love sir Harold westerling but I think
it's because I love the actor
um I think he I watch Outlander so I
don't know if you watch Outlander but
grandma tavish is such a great actor I
wanted to see more of him though I
didn't see enough of him but I agree
with you about the kids actually I think
in terms of the scene the entire the
scene that sort of
defined
like heartbreak for me in the whole
season was the scene
um between aymond and Luke on the
dragons
you know at the end and the way number
one the way the scene prior to that when
Eamon wants to take his eye and there's
that there's there's just there's such
quintessential like the bully and the
the schoolyard kid that gets bullied
both actors played those scenes to such
Perfection I mean here here were actors
that you didn't see a ton of the rest of
the season and yet you knew exactly who
they were and you felt for them
and I know I mean I feel like you might
have a different opinion from me but
people were mad that Eamon had that
moment of regret
when he dies that he was like that look
of like oh I didn't mean to kill him
some people were like no I wanted it to
be intentional and he's happy about it
but I loved that he that look was the
look of the Season that was the moment
where I was like oh my God he didn't
mean to he feels bad like he didn't mean
to do it and that registration on his
face
of what have I done
and the consequences that it's going to
have for the future but I thought both
actors did such a brilliant job in that
moment when they came out of the storm
where he came out of the Luke comes out
of the storm I call him Luke and he and
he you think he's going to be okay
and it's so quiet there's I don't think
there was a score there was anything and
then
and then you see the chum
coming down so so House of the Dragons
so Game of Thrones I'm like who thought
of The Chum that was brilliant but it
was disgusting but it was brilliant but
I but I agree with you that those those
actors were great okay any actors Not
actors but characters you didn't like
yeah I mean I feel like there's obvious
ones for sure I feel like the the Two
Brothers From Hell
aegon and Eamon uh it's really easy to
root against them to be honest I mean
they really set up aegon especially to
be despicable and just absolutely one of
the worst people in in the entire show
if not the entire show when it comes to
the type of person he is the type of
stuff he enjoys uh this the way he does
it want any type of ruling whatsoever he
doesn't want his responsibility but at
the same time he's willing to indulge in
everything that comes with it when it
comes to that episode episode nine aegon
is just the worst of the worst the show
really did him no favors as far as
anyone who wants to root for him uh and
Eamon I know a lot of people like Eamonn
which I'm a little bit disappointed in I
can't lie I
yeah he's absolutely horrific in the
book and that's why I also was one of
those people who said that I wish he was
kind of a little bit more enjoying the
moment and I didn't like that he was
kind of regretting that moment because I
feel like Eamon very much is spelled out
to be the main villain as far as the
main threat as to the to the blacks
inside Fire and Blood because Eamonn has
a vagar and because Eamon is considered
to be a good fighter amen is it's
supposed to be kind of like the Darth
Vader of the show maybe not the
manipulative one who's controlling the
strings like an Otto but he is the one
who has the weapon of mass destruction
that can destroy anything and he also
happens to be a really good fighter and
he has a lot of anger issues so I feel
like that's the perfect villain uh the
perfect chemical mix for revealing so
amen is definitely someone that I'm
happy to root against
that actor Ewan Mitchell he's brilliant
he is so good I mean he really does make
you hate him and I feel like of the two
brothers I hated him more because I just
he just has that the other one
he just he seems like just a mess up
like I want to say f up he's an F up
he's just that guy that you know he just
doesn't care he has no ambition
whatsoever
and aiming to me seems more evil like
all out and out like pure evil and we'll
go and seek out evil until that moment
where he was like oh my God what did I
do
um what did you think about Laris the
foot
how could I forget about layers another
horrific human being he's the silent
killer yeah kind of like not in your
face as much but when you look over the
whole season he was I think the most
evil his moment when he killed his uh
brother and his father in that fire I
felt like his whole speech after that
really built up who he was when he was
talking about the weakness and the Folly
of having children as far as they're
just an anchor that weighs you down and
you want to convince yourself that if
you have these children that you're
building towards something but he said
that children are your Folly and
children can be your downfall which
obviously he's talking about killing his
own father but by the end of that scene
when we cut back to him we see that he's
almost talking to Allison in a very
nonchalant kind of manner knowing what
he's done almost like this is like
another Tuesday for him where he's like
yeah I killed my father and my brother
but you know what I ever I did it for
you right and it's like wow this guy is
a really Disturbed individual who might
be the most psychotic in the entire show
which obviously we have a huge array of
sociopaths but I feel like he is
definitely the top one of them all
because of his uh just absolutely
disregard for his own family I agree he
was the most out and out evil I think
some people said Otto Hightower but Auto
Hightower I think was just ambitious for
his daughter and for her lineage and
what he thought was he saw an
opportunity and he took it and he
certainly whispered in her ear a lot and
you know whispered in other people's
ears and and was a mastermind behind the
scenes but in terms of all and out what
about Kristen Cole though how
what a great character turn like what a
great because when it started out and he
that the scene that I like I said I
called the sexy episode where he gets
seduced
and by the way they had a lot of time to
change their minds I mean it takes a
long time to get armor off
you know it took a long time yes yeah he
had he had a well first he said no but
you know she was you know taken off the
arm pieces and taken off the back thing
and he could have said no but and then I
think that was his downfall in my
opinion was not that he was so mad at
her
for after he proposed and said run away
with me and she said no I don't think it
was the rejection I think he was mad at
himself and he could just never
recognize reconcile that he took an oath
he went against it he and and he never
forgave himself and that's why he let
himself fall apart because I think if it
was just about her
or went down the dark side if it was
just about her he would have gotten over
it but it was he blames her for his own
downfall when it was really his choice
yeah yeah and I feel like it's it's one
of those things every time I say that
there is a villain I forget about
another villain my God there's no
shortage of them because the greens are
all pretty bad uh amen aegon Kristen
Cole is another one that I was just off
board since like after that scene and
after that moment when he did the whole
run away with me thing there was a
couple people who were like oh I feel
him in that moment and I was like what
are you doing this is the the queen to
be you can't just be like run away with
me and expect her to leave everything
behind and I know that's kind of what he
wanted but it's also kind of selfish if
you really think about it on his regard
considering he is supposed to be a
kingsguard he really does feel like in
that moment if I have this opportunity
for her to run away with me I can escape
all my responsibility and all my
failures so I did break my oath and my
way out of this now is by escaping with
rhaenyra so that was almost like his own
way to save his own butt and that's why
I was like man this guy's selfish so you
don't think do you think he loved her
I don't think he loved her no
yeah I I don't know I mean I I feel like
he's definitely one of those guys who's
just never experienced anything before
and that was his first time experience
anything right so maybe that was his
first time experiencing that kind of uh
joy and excitement as far as being
wanted by this girl and now he's like
run away with me and that's my best way
out of my responsibility of breaking my
oath and when she said no he was like
crap now I'm stuck with my with my own
consequences of my actions yeah that he
would have to stay there and deal with
that and he he couldn't handle that he
reminded me of like when you're young
and the guy in the school that's trying
to kiss you in the playground and then
when you reject him he starts pulling
your hair because he's like all of a
sudden he hates you and starts calling
you names that was you're right was so
immature that he couldn't deal with
he didn't think much about the
consequences of his actions he kind of
just went with it and then wanted to
blame renera
but that scene where he kills lenor's
lover at the wedding I mean I knew we
had to have a scene like that would
rival the Red Wedding in a sense some
weddings never go well
but that was in my opinion the most
brutal
disgusting to watch scene of the entire
season yeah it absolutely was and it
really did feel like that came from a
variety of different places so I feel
like the writers are really a really
good job of showing you who Kristen Cole
was from the very beginning in episode I
believe three when she asks raniera asks
Kristin Cole if she will ever be
accepted as Queen he kind of gives a a
smug look as far as like a reluctance
when he says oh they won't have a choice
but to accept you almost saying like
even I won't really accept you as Queen
but you won't really have a choice
because that's who was declared as Queen
and then in moments afterwards words
episode 7 we see Allison talk about
lenore's activities and he gives a a he
does a little laugh almost making fun of
Lenor and his activities knowing that he
killed his lover and it's showing you
that Kristin Cole has always been this
person Kristen Cole has always been kind
of a darker person kind of a person who
really has these ideals in his head of
how people should be and if they're not
this type of way then they shouldn't be
respected or they shouldn't be any type
of have any type of responsibility and
that's why obviously we see him kill
Lord beetsberry as well but that scene
when he kills
um Joffrey was his name the Knight of
kisses I believe uh was was showing you
that Kristen Cole has been having all
this pent up rage and pent-up aggression
and and kind of pent up Darkness inside
of him this whole time and he was
actually able to bring it out in that
moment which was absolutely awful anyone
else you want to give an honorable
mention to
I loved Lenor I loved um it's his name
is John McMillan who played Lenor
which we'll get to our favorite scenes
and moments of the season but he had my
number one favorite moment of the entire
season
I love Lenore absolutely lovely do you
think he's coming back in season two
you think they're gonna bring him back
they're so far off from the book for
anyone who wants to know there's so many
changes that's happened from the book
but they've they've done so many
different side like changes when it
comes to the book changes so I'm curious
what they do with his character because
sky's the limit
considering that they even mentioned
that they still have his Dragon see
smoke there so I'm just kind of I'm kind
of worried about my boys see smoke
that's his uh his baby boy dragon so so
for people who haven't read the book
what are a couple of like the biggest
changes
um that the show and the biggest
departures that the show made from the
book if I'm if I mean that's the biggest
one
Lenor is not supposed to run off with
his lover to essos and do this whole
thing Lenor is just done in the book
um and then I feel like another big one
was
aemond obviously is supposed to get
Veigar Lena was supposed to have a guard
at a very young age I believe at 11 or
12 is when she claims vegar and then
everything else is more like nitpicky
for me when it comes to Lena and Damon I
had a lot of thoughts on Lena and Damon
where their relationship was supposed to
be very tight-knit and their his
relationship with his daughters were
supposed to be
supposedly incredible in the book and
really well done and he supposedly he
loves his daughters and I don't think
we've had one scene with Damon and his
daughters in the show so I feel like
that's my biggest uh disappointment when
it comes to the change in the book that
would have been interesting to see so
what did you think about Damon and
Rainier there's
there's so much
relationship but listen
when they when they kissed on the beach
when they finally came together and
kissed on the beach and she was just
like let's do it let's get married let's
get rid of Elena let's figure it out I I
was all for it because that was her love
that was her passion that's who she
wanted they had chemistry he had
chemistry with both actresses that was
off the charts I thought Kudos Matt
Smith for pulling it off in both cases
but uh yeah what did you think
I I I might have the hottest take here
too where I I kind of I I'm okay with it
obviously I'm not against it in any type
of way but I also don't get the hype
necessarily where I feel like it's maybe
there for rhaenyra right where she does
feel that connection towards him but I
don't really necessarily feel it from
Damon and I feel like they might be
doing that on purpose potentially
showing you that Damon still might have
some sort of arterial motive when it
comes to being with rhaenyra but I don't
necessarily
I'm not necessarily with the whole Uncle
with his niece relationship being the
most goals hashtag goals
I'm not condoning that part of it per se
but look this is Game of Thrones yeah
yeah I'm desensitized to the whole thing
at this point I'm like look whoever you
do but I I felt the chemistry I think I
felt the chemistry between on on his
side a little bit more with him and
Millie the younger character
than I did
you know with Emma's character
um but I think it was more to do with
where they were in their lives than
anything else
uh so let's dive into our favorite
moments
our favorite episodes overall sort of
the highlights of the season and I'll
just jump in and say that my number one
actually I kind of tipped my hat to it
my number one favorite moment of the
season was the very last moment of
episode seven and episode seven was my
favorite episode Driftwood when Lenor
gets on the boat
and you
that there was something about that
actor's performance
that freedom that sense of freedom and
that sense of he's probably been
tortured his whole life and not been
free to be who he was and that reveal
that great reveal that he was I mean
they they hint to it in those moments
before but you see he's alive and he's
you know
starting a new life there was and just
the water spring on his face and his
hair is short and just there was just
that was pure Liberation and that's
something that no other character on the
show got
that was my Numero Uno what's your
Numero Uno if you can choose it's a
moment of the season I I feel like
I feel like a lot of people and maybe
man I'm going back to my roots okay in a
Game of Thrones fan being a battle of
the bastards fan uh for anyone who knows
that episode uh I love battles I
absolutely love battles and I think a
lot of people forgot maybe because it
was episode three but that battle in the
stepstones was so incredible with Damon
taking on the entire Army on his own
with sea smoke and Lenor coming in to
help Damon in that very moment with
Corliss showing up with the victory of
him pulling the body of the crab feeder
with the building up of the crap feeder
as far as being a major villain and
Damon just killing him in two seconds
like all that to me was just so expertly
done and so much communicated and not a
single word uttered in that entire 15 17
minute sequence I thought it was
absolutely perfect and it might be my
favorite moment in the entire season and
that was episode three so I have to
gives them love to that moment actually
episode three was my second favorite
episode of the Season it was seven and
then it was three because that was also
the episode when renera was like with
the the white stag saw yeah with the
boar and then came out and that was one
of my other favorite moments of the
season when she came out with all the
blood on her
it was all in her blonde hair and it was
in her outfit and she had that badass
moment where she just was just like this
was like my Luke Skywalker from The Last
Jedi moment where she's like like piece
of cake you know and the fact that she
let the white stag go and she said no
and she and and so she
just the humanity of her character but
then when she walked out and I love the
Defiance of Millie alcock's performance
I just love kind of what a little Rebel
she was that was a phenomenal episode
but Matt Smith Damon's last moment in
that episode
when he's standing there and he's all
dirty and this was sort of like the
moment that both of those characters
fully owned their badassness I thought
but yeah it was incredible and obviously
they're both covered in blood both
showing you kind of I heard a lot of
people say this so I'm not necessarily
original but it both kind of showing you
like a rebirth of who they are showing
you that they are now like reborn in
this new age if who they are and who
they've become and I really did think
that they did a really good job showing
you that and I love that Damon didn't
utter a word that entire episode except
for the very beginning which shows you a
lot about who his character is and shows
you that Matt Smith is an incredible
actor who really did create his own
Dynamic with the character of Damon gave
a lot to that character I feel like if
there's any character that really
expanded from what the book was it was
definitely both viserys and Damon when
it comes to Matt Smith as well so
yeah he's he is he is amazing and he
didn't have as much screen time as I
thought he would have given that they
kind of used him to sell the show
because he was the biggest name
but when he came on screen you're right
there was that whole sequence he didn't
have words and that was that was an
amazing in terms of battles and Wars
other than the dragons themselves
visually that was the coolest I thought
coolest visuals of the whole of the
whole season
um what about I in episode seven when I
said driftmark was that was my favorite
episode
when you finally got that moment between
renera and Allison where she cuts her
and they have that fight and renera says
now you finally everyone can finally see
who you are that to me again
quintessential moment that that was the
build up we were waiting for that when
the two of them just go at each other
and you see that viserys is always going
to side with his daughter and I think
Allison realizes it in that moment that
no matter what he's always gonna have
her back but that exchange between the
two actresses I was waiting for that
moment and it's it's not you know as big
a moment as some of the others in terms
of epicness and the visuals but I
thought acting wise
um awesome what else did you love what
other moments in the season yeah I feel
like episode 8 was an episode I think it
might be the highest rated episode of
the season and for a good reason because
we got so much in that episode that's
viserys's last episode that's the moment
where he walks down uh the doors open
and he comes to defend his daughter and
luceris as well to be the area of drift
Mark I feel like that moment was
incredible as far as showing you
viserys's last dying wish to be for
rhaenyra to be for his family uh and to
be for peace obviously we see that in
the dinner scene as well when he asks
for peace between the family that and
entire episode had so many moments when
it comes to the Last Supper him walking
down to the Iron Throne Damon cutting
off vaman's head out of nowhere
everything in that entire episode just
built an incredible moment after moment
and I feel like that one is just
phenomenal yeah I see why I think that
was pain it was painful to watch in
terms of
um to be not to be too dark but if
anybody has ever watched or been around
a loved one passing
the breathing the labor breathing Patty
really they the writers allowed him the
time to really go there as an actor and
I don't I've never seen a death on
screen ever portrayed so realistically
before it was hard to watch for that
reason I wouldn't put it up there as my
favorite episode for one reason I'm
gonna be very superficial it was really
hard to look at Sarah's through the
whole episode he was looking some kind
of gnarly he did not look healthy and it
was just visually I mean good for the
actor and good for the makeup Department
that's probably gonna win an Emmy but
that was it was it was emotionally hard
to watch but visually very very hard to
watch but I think a lot of people also
love that moment when Matt Smith picks
up the crown when Damon picks up the
crown
and when he's you know he's finally
trying to help his brother and his
brother says I'm good but then he holds
that crown for that moment and there's
so much there's so much in that moment
too and then the you know the supper
where for a second you think that
there's going to be peace
between them but he gets his dying wish
in a sense and then I heard some people
say this that they never actually that
that supper where everybody's kind of
toasting each other and getting along
never actually happened but it was
through viserys's
eyes of what he saw in his delusion that
that didn't actually happen what do you
think about that
I don't know about that I think it
happened yeah I don't think we've ever
seen like a vision sequence in Game of
Thrones or a dream sequence that you
know tricked the audience for any reason
I feel like it actually happened and
it's there to show you that there was
this tiny bit of possibility for peace
there uh but even though if it was just
this small bit it was all based on the
shoulders of viserys and as soon as he
was gone all that potential was Gone
with it and I feel like that was there
to show you that even if there was this
possibility for peace it all rested on
viserys's shoulders so it's tough now
that he's gone and as soon as he's gone
all hell breaks loose yeah it was
interesting that they chose to do it in
the episode that they did and then the
last two episodes one was obviously you
know Green for and then the last episode
was house black like but each one was
sort of told through each woman's eyes
and and even in episode nine I felt like
I was always team renera and in that
moment I you know in episode nine I was
team Allison for a second I really saw
her point of view and I love that they
did that that they really showed you the
story and her justification for doing
things
um who I mean on a whole did you side
with her at all or did you were you
always no you didn't I didn't I'm sorry
always TV and era always uh Team black
uh from the very beginning but obviously
that's another thing obviously that's
been a change you asked me before from
the books to the shows that was another
change the whole mistaking of aegon's
vision and A Song of Ice and Fire that
whole thing was there really added in
the show to actually give you that
endearing feeling towards Allison and to
make you feel for her perspective and to
make you feel like maybe if it is if
this is his dying wish then there is a
feeling that oh I get her I get her
perspective I get where she's coming
from whereas in the book it's not there
at all and it's much more cold-blooded
in the sense of like I'm just gonna do
this because this is my son and he
should be king Because I Said So versus
this is my you know husband's dying wish
so I that's another addition from from
the show did you like that aspect of it
though did you enjoy that part the fact
that it was that sort of her mistaking
and him not knowing who he was talking
to
uh no no we're the opposite on
everything
I don't know I just feel like when it
comes to the type of confusion there was
a lot of built up there where episode
one is supposed to be it starts off with
the great Council of 101 which is the
Council of deciding viserys versus
rhaenys and who should be Queen and this
great Council of 101 is the kind of
almost like saying a law was set into
place or a custom where the male Heir
will always have the better Advantage
than a female there and that was built
up the entire season telling you that a
male layer is always going to have a
better claim to the Iron Throne than a
female Heir so when the series dies
Otto uses the Council of 101 and so does
Allison to say this is why my son should
be king because all the kingdoms in
Westeros will accept a male Heir versus
a female layer we even see Otto say that
when he leaves King's Landing I believe
in episode six so I felt like that was
was built up up in the show and built up
in the book and they kind of undercut it
a tiny bit by making you like feel for
Allison and I was like yeah we don't
have to feel for hours
fine I also think
Otto uses that as an excuse he's like oh
it's to keep the peace because people
will never accept you know a female
except a queen and when there's a male
Heir so I'm only doing this for the good
of the piece but it's like I'm not 100
I'm not 100 buying it in in terms of
that so
um any so in terms of the most
heartbreaking or sad moments
from the season what would you choose
I mean I feel like you named quite a few
of them viserys's death for sure his
last words being my love thinking about
his first wife
Emma and then Lenor I actually my heart
broke
um for Leonor in the wedding episode
when Joffrey got killed and when he lets
he lets out this little cry he lets out
like a like a a cry or a yell and I felt
like that actor nailed it even if it's
like one second of just feeling his pain
you feel that amount of pain that he
feels I felt like that was heartbreaking
so I feel like those two moments for
sure are probably probably the most
heartbreaking moments in the entire show
for me yeah I thought Luke's death but I
also thought the very last moment of the
entire season the the choice of the
director to have Damon walk up to renera
and they turn their backs to the camera
and turn towards the fire which so
symbolic and you don't see her reaction
but then you see when she turns around
you don't see the Heartbreak but then
you turn you see the Vengeance that's
what they show you and that's season two
like get ready that's what they're doing
you're they're getting you ready for
that and they did a great job the whole
season of
you know making you want more and I
really hope it's not going to be till
2024 that we that we that we get that um
any other badass moments that you loved
I did also love when renera comes to
take the egg from Damon I think it was a
I want to say episode two or three when
she comes to reclaim the egg and she
rides in on her dragon
hmm
I was like okay this is It's on that I
think that was our first dragon moment
of the Season too our first major Dragon
moment yeah I feel like all the dragon
moments were incredible I love I love
the moment where Damon goes up to Verma
Thor which is the dragon in the finale
we see Damon go inside this cave and
meet this other dragon and we're kind of
confused as far as what's going on and
who this dragon is that's actually the
dragon of King jaharis who is the old
King who we see in episode one who has
this old old Dragon it's the second
oldest Dragon to vagar who is resting in
this cave but that scene where Damon
comes up to the dragon singing this old
Valerian hymn almost taming the dragon
controlling the dragon bonding with the
dragon showing it what it is to be a
Targaryen what it is to have a bond with
these creatures and I feel like that
scene communicated so much when it comes
to what it is to have this kind of
relationship with these creatures where
they're giant majestical magical
creatures that a lot of it is just being
brave enough to go up to them that's
that's a lot of what the connection is
and the rest of it is just really
focusing on that Targaryen nature and
that Targaryen bond which gives you the
edge of connecting with these creatures
and we see the moment where they close
up on the eyes of the dragon and then on
the eye of Damon I feel like that moment
communicated so much and shows you that
these creatures do have a relationship
and a bond to the targaryens that is
unlike anything else inside this world
so I really love that moment for sure
isn't that also someone told me who you
know who read the book that that's
something that they really delve into in
the book is more of the relationship
between the dragons and the dragon
Riders and you didn't necessarily see
those relationships as much in season
one now is probably the biggest bonding
moment that you saw
that's what I that's probably one of my
biggest disappointments and obviously
this is just nitpicky because it's not
necessarily necessary but I would love
to have seen more of that because like
you said the books really does a good
job of showing you that these creatures
every single one of these Dragon Riders
has a special relationship it's like a
dog it really is like having your own
dog training your dog communicating with
it that's what we see those tiny moments
with luceris and a-rax at the end as
well we see lucerius trying to get a
racks to focus and he's like focus aurax
focus like be with me there's moments
where every Dragon Rider has a special
relationship and a different
relationship with their dragons and I I
wish we got more of it I'm glad we got
what we got in the finale because it
definitely communicated a lot but yes
there's a ton more dragon and dragon
rider in the book well the the dragon
visuals themselves were mind-blowing
every every time I see something like
that I'm looking for cracks and I'm
looking for things that don't look so
realistic or aren't so cool and I
couldn't find any they were they were
incredible so
um so as we wrap up I want to talk about
the future of where this
series is going and you have a huge
Insight because you know where it's
going but where do you think I know
they've said that they're not going to
do as many time jumps in season two
that it's going to be maybe only the
first
you know not even the first year of the
Civil War will be covered in season two
so it sounds like they're going to slow
down in terms of the timeline but things
are going to get you know much more uh
violent but where do you see it going in
season two and where would you like to
see it go
I feel like it's going kind of where the
show left off where it's the kids the
kids being kind of the flag bearers of
team rainera and and then obviously the
kids of Allison being the flag bearers
of Team aegon Versus Them doing their
own side missions in their own side
quests throughout all of uh Westeros and
trying to get the the entire Seven
Kingdoms on board with their side and I
feel like that's a really cool angle to
now explore a little bit of Westeros
during this time period because I feel
like they did a really good job of
setting up the Targaryen Civil War but
now that we have it we get to see the
Eerie we get to see Winterfell we get to
see all the iconic locations from Game
of Thrones and I feel like that's really
what they're building up to is showing
you more of that and also showing you I
feel like they're gonna do a really good
job in season two of showing you more
dragons and more Dragon taming more
Dragon relationships Dragon
communication I feel like all that kind
of stuff is going to be in season two
building up more of this Civil War
because eventually those dragons are
going to fly well Andreas this was such
a pleasure diving into house of the
Dragon with you I loved your Insight on
the book I love that you I love that you
and I were very opposite in what we
didn't like for the most part
we just didn't agree on everything but I
think we can both agree that it was an
incredible season and it's not fair that
I think we have to wait till 2024 to get
more
I'm hoping they could possibly speed it
up I'm I'm I was so mad I'm still mad I
don't know how they could be like well
we'll see how the first season does and
then we'll start considering season two
and I was like what no after the first
episode dropped they should have been
heavy into the writing and production
should be underway now they should have
been concerned shooting it while season
one was aired they should have been on
this but yeah that's the one biggest
disappointment of all of House of the
Dragon how long they waited I want to
thank you so much for joining today and
let everybody know where they can find
you give yourself a plug yeah you can
find me on Twitter and Instagram at
squad leader Ace and you can also follow
my YouTube channel and my uh Tick Tock
at uh first cut so you can follow me on
there well thanks again that was tons of
fun and thank you all for watching we
hope you enjoyed this breakdown of the
brilliant first season of House of the
dragon and that you loved it as much as
we did and we will see you hopefully
soon enough for season two bye